you're calling here for four percent  growth out of China this year why well I  think that we had colossal credit bubble  in China and that this credit bubble is  now being gradually deflated and will  bring about problems in the real estate  market and among some major players in  the commodity markets as well so overall  if i look at export figures from china  and they are very closely correlated to  overall economic growth then there is a  huge discrepancy between what China  reports and what China's trading  partners are reporting so if you look at  the figures of China than exports are  still growing if you look at the trade  figures say China exports to Taiwan so  China records exports of socks so so on  so much but Taiwan reports import from  china at the much lower level so which  figures are more reliable I think the  figures of the trading partners of China  more reliable and they would suggest  that growth has slowed down considerably